i now come to the statement prime
minister
thank you very much mr speaker
mr speaker with your permission i would
like to make a statement and first i
want to express my deepest gratitude to
sue gray and all the people who have
contributed
to this report which i have placed in
the library of this house and which the
government has published in full today
for everyone to read
i will address its findings in this
statement
but firstly i want to say sorry
and i'm sorry for the things we simply
didn't get right and also sorry for the
way that this matter has been handled
and it's no use
saying that this or that was within the
rules and it's no use saying that people
were working hard
[Applause]
this pandemic
was hard
for everyone
we asked people across this country to
make the most extraordinary sacrifices
not to meet loved ones not to visit
relatives before they died and i
understand the anger that people feel
but mr speaker it isn't enough
to say sorry
this is a moment when let's look at
ourselves
in the mirror and we must learn
and while the metropolitan police must
yet complete their investigation
and that means there are no details of
specific events in sue grey's report
i of course accept
sue gray's general findings in full
and above all her recommendation that we
must learn from these events and act now
with respect to the events under police
investigation she says and i quote
no conclusions should be drawn or
inferences made from this other than it
is now for the police to consider the
relevant material in relation to those
incidents but more broadly
she finds that there is significant
learning to be drawn from these events
which must be addressed immediately
across government
this does not need to wait for the
police investigations to be concluded mr
speaker
i get it and i will fix it
and i want to say
[Applause]
[Music]
and i want to say
to the people of this country
i know
what the issue is
yes mr speaker yes
yes it's whether this government can be
trusted to deliver
and i say mr speaker yes we can be
trusted
yes we can be trusted to deliver i'd
like to thank sue gray for the diligence
and professionalism with which she's
carried out her work it's no fault of
hers that she's only been able to
produce an update today not the full
report
the prime minister repeatedly assured
the house that the guidance was followed
and the rules were followed
but we now know
that 12 cases have reached the threshold
for criminal investigation
which i remind the house means that
there is evidence of serious and
flagrant breaches of lockdown
including including the party on the
20th of may 2020 which we know the prime
minister attended
and the party on the 13th of november
2020 in the prime minister's flat
there can be no doubt that the prime
minister himself is now subject to
criminal investigation
the prime minister must keep his promise
to publish sue grey's report in full
when it is available
but it is already clear that the report
discloses the most damning conclusion
possible
over the last two years the british
public have been asked to make the most
heart-wrenching sacrifices
a collective trauma
endured by all
enjoyed by none
funerals have been missed
dying relatives unvisited
every family has been marked by what
we've been through
and revelations about the promised
behavior have forced us all to rethink
and relive those darkest moments
many have been overcome by rage
by grief
and even guilt
guilt
but because they stuck to the law they
did not see their parents one last time
guilt that because they didn't bend the
rules
their children went months without
seeing friends
guilt that because they did as they were
asked they didn't go and visit lonely
relatives
but people shouldn't feel guilty they
should feel pride
in themselves and their country
because by abiding by those rules
they've saved the lives of people they
will probably never meet
they have shown the deep public spirit
and the love and respect for others that
has always characterized this nation at
its best
the covet regulations impose significant
restrictions on the freedoms of members
of the public
they had a right to expect their prime
minister
to have read the rules to understand the
meaning of the rules and indeed those
around them to have done around him to
have done so too and to set an example
in following those rules what the grey
report does show
is that number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10. which was it
[Applause]
my right
[Applause]
it's a very important question i want to
hear the answer even if other people
don't prime minister
uh no mr speaker that is not what the uh
grey report says
[Applause]
but if she i i
suggest that she waits to see uh the
conclusion of the inquiry